Ich glaube, das ist eines der großen
Missverständnisse, auch der Pandemie:
Spalten tun nicht die Regeln, spalten
tun Menschen, die sich gegen die Solidarität
entscheiden. Wenn ich in einer Gesellschaft
lebe, dann muss
ich auch ein bisschen schauen, was meine Entscheidungen
mit den anderen machen
und das kam zum Beispiel in deiner
Begründung in keinster Weise vor.
13 Fragen. Hier kommt die erste:
Sind Nachteile für Menschen, die sich nicht
impfen lassen wollen gerecht oder nicht?
Wenn ihr sagt ja, dann würde ich euch
bitten, geht auf das grüne Feld. Wenn ihr sagt
eher nein, dann bitte auf dem gelben
Feld platzieren. So, jetzt wissen wir,
wo ihr steht, aber wo steht ihr eigentlich?
Zwei Drittel der Deutschen sind
inzwischen vollständig geimpft und haben damit
auch fast vollständig ihre Freiheitsrechte
zurück. Menschen, die sich nicht impfen
lassen wollen, obwohl sie könnten,
müssen dagegen weiter mit Einschränkungen leben.
Zum Beispiel dürfen sie unter 2G
Regelung nicht in jedes Café oder Restaurant
oder in die Clubs. Außerdem müssen
sie Corona-Tests selber zahlen und mancher
diskutiert sogar eine Erhöhung
der Krankenkassenbeiträge. "Ja, gut so",
sagen die einen, denn nur die Impfung
hilft auf dem Weg zurück
in die vollständige Freiheit.
"Ne, total ungerecht", sagen die anderen,
denn Impfunwillige würden pauschal
an den Pranger gestellt werden. Das sei
eine Impfpflicht durch die Hintertür
und das schade wiederum dem gesellschaftlichen
Klima. Meine Gäste sind heute
natürlich erst mal uneins. Die spannende Frage wird
sein: Schaffen wir es, eine Kompromisslinie
zu identifizieren?
Wenn ja, wie sieht sie aus und wo könnte
sie verlaufen? Schaffen also diese Damen
und Herren heute sich aufeinander
zuzubewegen, wenigstens in Teilaspekten?
Jetzt aber erst mal die Frage an euch:
Wo würdet ihr euch platzieren? Auf der grünen
Seite: Ja, Nachteile für Ungeimpfte
sind durchaus akzeptabel und gerecht
oder auf der gelben Seite:
Nein, auf keinen Fall. Das schadet
dem gesellschaftlichen Klima.
Schreibt's mir gerne in die Kommentare.
Das Spielprinzip ist klar, denke ich.
Also wenn ihr der Gegenseite in irgendeinem
Punkt zustimmt, dann könnt ihr gerne
einen Schritt auf sie zugehen, also nach vorne.
Und wenn ihr sagt: Grundsätzlich
finde ich deine Meinung gar nicht so schlecht,
aber in dem Fall erzählst du
wirklich totalen Quatsch, dann könnt
ihr auch wieder einen Schritt
zurückgehen. Das heißt, ihr könnt hier richtig Bewegung
ins Spiel bringen. Mein Ziel wäre es am Ende
dieser Folge möglichst viele von euch
hier in der Mitte zu versammeln,
im sogenannten Kompromissfeld.
Bei dieser Frage bin ich sehr gespannt,
wie weit ihr am Ende hier vorne steht.
13 Fragen, hier kommt Frage Nummer
zwei und die geht an Erik. Erik, du betreibst
eine Bar und du hast dich
entschieden, die 2G Regel durchzusetzen. Das heißt,
es dürfen nur Genesene und Geimpfte
in deine Bar. Warum?
Es ist in erster Linie eine betriebswirtschaftliche
Entscheidung.
Die komplette Ausgestaltung von 2G
und 3G ist nicht auf meinem Mist gewachsen,
es ist eine politische Entscheidung.
Aber die Wahl, die ich hier habe an der Stelle
ist: Auf der einen Seite sage ich bei 2G,
ich kann den Laden wieder komplett voll
machen. Bei 3G habe ich die Einschränkung,
dass ich nur ein Drittel der Plätze
besetzen kann und an der Stelle war
es für mich einfach eine wirtschaftliche
Entscheidung auf der einen Seite,
plus alle anderen Gründe, die es natürlich
auch noch gibt. Ich bin
nicht nur Gastronom an der Stelle,
der betriebswirtschaftlich denkt,
sondern ich sehe auch noch die soziale
Verantwortung. Und jetzt zu sagen,
ich mache jetzt einfach für alle wieder
auf und tue so, als wäre nie was passiert,
wäre dann denke ich der falsche Weg.
Ich habe grade gesehen, du
bist nach vorne gegangen. Warum?
Weil ich ihm in dem Punkt
total recht gebe und vor allem darin,
dass es eine politische
Entscheidung ist. Genau die finde ich aber falsch,
weil ich kann durchaus seine Lage
nachvollziehen, dass man nach all dem,
was wir hinter uns haben,
wirtschaftlich denken muss. Und deswegen erwarte
ich von der Politik, dass sie menschlich
denkt und diese Entscheidung nicht an ihn
abgibt, weil ich glaube nicht, dass du
Ladenbesitzer geworden bist, weil du Bock
hast, Menschen zu kontrollieren oder Menschen
aus deinem Laden rausschmeißen
zu müssen. Und das läuft für mich
gerade extrem falsch. Mein Eindruck ist,
dass die Gesellschaft gerade sehr gespalten
ist und das muss aufhören.
Wir müssen miteinander reden und vor allem
müssen wir einander zuhören.
Meine Erfahrung ist, dass die Gespräche,
die man führt, meistens darum gehen,
dass jeder seine Argumente loswird
und den anderen versucht zu überzeugen,
weil er selber hat ja recht. Aber
eigentlich ginge es darum, der Gegenseite
mal zuzuhören. Und das ist mein großer
Vorsatz für heute, denn ich glaube,
dass wir schon auch gemeinsame
Nenner haben.
Ich halte fest, es bewegen sich
viele Menschen schon in Richtung Mitte
und das nach zwei Sätzen. Das ist
toll. Schön zu sehen! Lutz, Erik sagt, er macht
2G, auch aus einem gewissen
wirtschaftlichen Zwang heraus. Du sagst,
du würdest gerne 3G machen, darfst es aber
nicht als Sprecher der Club Commission,
das heißt, wenn du für die Clubs in Berlin
sprichst, sondern du musst mit 2G leben.
-Warum findest du das problematisch?
-Wir haben uns für 3G ausgesprochen, weil
wir nach 18 Monaten Stillstand
inklusiv sein wollten. Wir wollten wieder
Nachtleben für alle bieten. Und nachdem jetzt
auch jeder ein Angebot hat
und nachdem wir auch die vulnerable
Gruppen schützen konnten, glaube ich,
ist es dann auch an der Zeit, dass wir sagen:
Jetzt kann auch jeder selbst
entscheiden, selbstbestimmt
entscheiden, ob man sich dem Risiko aussetzt.
Dafür würden wir natürlich aber
trotzdem verlangen, dass man sich testen lässt.
Das ist ganz wichtig. Clubs sind ein ganz
wichtiger Kleister in der Gesellschaft.
Sie bringen Menschen zusammen in einem
Kontext, wo man eben auch Leute trifft,
die man vorher nicht gekannt hat, in einer sehr lockeren
Atmosphäre. Das ist ganz
wichtig, dass wir da nicht
schon wieder eine Trennung herbeiführen
zwischen Menschen, die das dürfen
und Menschen, die es nicht dürfen.
Und ich wünsche mir einfach,
dass wir da jetzt ein Stück weiterkommen
und den Menschen wieder mehr
Verantwortung geben und sie selbst entscheiden lassen.
Jetzt ist Elke ganz weit
nach hinten gerannt. Warum?
Ein Test schützt nicht vor Corona.
Jeder, der getestet ist, schützt in erster Linie
mal die nächsten zwei bis drei
Stunden seine Umgebung, nicht länger. Der Test
gilt aber in der Zwischenzeit nur noch
24 Stunden, davor 48 Stunden und PCR Test
jetzt 48 Stunden, davor 72 Stunden.
Ich habe in der Praxis Patienten erlebt,
die 48 Stunden nach PCR Test
eine Vollausprägung von Covid hatten,
die eindeutig infektiös waren, die mit diesem Test,
der 48 Stunden davor getätigt
wurde, aber in jede Bahn, in jedes
Flugzeug, in jeden Club gekommen wären.
Von daher sage ich, ein Test ist
nicht gleichwertig mit einer Impfung.
Die Beschränkungen für Ungeimpfte
sind meiner Meinung nach gerechtfertigt,
da Ungeimpfte sich selbst nicht
schützen, sondern auf die Solidarität der Geimpften
hoffen, dass diese sowohl sich
selbst als auch die Ungeimpften schützen.
Friedemann geht du gerne in einen
Club, wo auch 3G gestattet ist?
Mit einem deutlich schlechteren
Gefühl als 2G. Und ich finde, das ist eines
der vielen Dilemmata dieser Pandemie,
dass man sehr genau und kleinteilig abwägen
muss. Ich bin auch einen kleinen
Schritt vorgegangen, als Lutz über Inklusion
gesprochen hat. Ich habe ein großes
Herz für die Clubkultur. Ich gehe selber gerne
feiern, aber im Zweifelsfall finde
ich, muss an der Stelle Inklusion zurückstehen
und Solidarität nach vorne gestellt
werden. Und ich finde das Signal, was man
damit im Endeffekt sendet ist, dass das Impfen
so was ist wie eine Lifestyle
Entscheidung, was für Schuhe ich mir
anziehe oder ob ich eine dicke Jacke
oder eine dünne Jacke anziehe und da hätte
ich mir auf jeden Fall eine andere Aussage
gewünscht. Wer sich in dieser Situation
nicht impfen lassen will, der darf
auch nicht darauf hoffen, dass wir alle
Rücksicht mit den Rücksichtslosen haben.
Gesellschaft funktioniert nur mit Solidarität.
Und eine Impfung
in einer Pandemie, die so
sicher und weitverbreitet ist, ist genau
dieses bisschen Solidarität,
was jeder und jede geben müsste.
-Jetzt ist Miriam-
-Jetzt hab ich sie nach hinten getrieben.
-Es tut mir leid!
-Du hast sie nach hinten getrieben, aber
vielleicht kriegen wir sie auch wieder
nach vorne. Miriam, du bist glaube
ich nicht geimpft. Das heißt, du
könntest jetzt sagen, du darfst jetzt nicht
in Clubs tanzen gehen und du darfst
auch nicht in seine Bar trinken gehen.
-Fühlst du dich diskriminiert?
-Zu 100 Prozent und der Satz Impfen ist
-eine Lifestyle-Entscheidung-
-Nein, ich sagte, das Signal, was man
aussendet, ist: Impfen ist so eine Entscheidung,
wo jeder so ein bisschen
nach Bauchgefühl gehen
kann. Und das finde ich falsch.
Ich finde es auch falsch, nach Bauchgefühl
zu gehen. Ich bin sehr dafür nach Zahlen
und Fakten zu gehen. Deswegen muss
ich noch mal kurz eins zurückgehen, was du
gesagt hast, Elke. Auch eine Impfung
schützt nicht das Umfeld. Das ist ja das,
was jetzt auf dem Tisch
liegt und ganz klar ist.
-Das stimmt nicht.
-Darf ich kurz ausreden? Eine Impfung
schützt vor allem einen selbst vor einem
möglichen schweren Verlauf. Und ich finde,
deswegen ist es keine
Bauchentscheidung, sondern ich persönlich zum Beispiel habe
einfach geguckt. Ich habe mir die Zahlen
angeguckt. Wie sieht es aus? Ich bin jung,
ich bin gesund, ich bin fit, ich bin
schlank. Wie groß ist meine Chance,
dass ich einen schweren Verlauf habe
im Vergleich zu wie groß ist meine Chance,
dass diese Impfung mir vielleicht
nicht gut tut? Und da bin ich zu dem Entschluss
gekommen, mich nicht impfen zu lassen.
Und diese Entscheidung muss man jedem Menschen
-über seinen eigenen Körper lassen.
-Darf ich kurz?
-Bitte!
-Das trifft eigentlich genau den Punkt,
Lutz war richtig, oder? Er meinte, es ist
eine individuelle Entscheidung zu sagen:
Ich nehme das Risiko auf mich jetzt in den Club
zu gehen, der 3G hat. Aber wir wissen
auch jetzt im Rahmen der Pandemie, dass es eben
keine individuelle Entscheidung ist,
weil ich ja dieses Virus auch unbemerkt
einfach weitergeben kann und ich mich
nicht nur selber infizieren kann. Im Rahmen
des Eigenschutzes kann ich sagen:
Okay, das Risiko nehme ich auf mich.
Aber in dem Augenblick,
wo ich es an meine Familie eintrage
oder an Kinder oder an Leute, die sich nicht
impfen lassen können bis zum heutigen
Zeitpunkt, darum geht es ja auch,
die mit zu schützen,
finde ich das schwierig.
Ich bin kein Mediziner, aber ich glaube
den Punkt haben wir längst überschritten.
Jetzt hat jeder ein Impfangebot.
Jeder, der geimpft ist, hat auch, wie du schon
gesagt hast, das Risiko
vermindert, dass man einen schweren Verlauf hat.
Und wie lange wollen wir eigentlich
diesen Prozess noch aufrechterhalten?
Bis der letzte Mahner befriedigt ist?
Wir sind jetzt bei einer hohen Impfquote
und wir sehen auch in anderen
Ländern, dass diese hohe Quote auch dazu geführt
hat, dass die Zahlen runtergehen, dass die Krankenhausbetten
nicht mehr belegt sind
oder geringer belegt sind. Und ich meine,
dass am Ende der Mensch selbst entscheiden
muss, und das ist auch eine sehr persönliche
Entscheidung, ob ich mich
impfen lasse oder nicht. Ich bin
geimpft und ich habe auch diese Entscheidung
selbst getroffen. Ich meine aber,
dass sich das nicht jemand anders abnehmen
-kann.
-Dann also mal ganz kurz, um das
klarzustellen: Wir reden einmal über
die Frage, ist das eine rein persönliche
Entscheidung oder ist es so wie Eric
sagt, eben nicht nur eine persönliche,
sondern auch eine darüber hinausgehend
solidarische Entscheidung, um andere Leute
zu schützen. Ich fasse nur kurz
zusammen, danach dürft ihr gleich. Wie Miriam sagt:
Moment mal, Impfung hilft vor allem
mir selbst. Das hilft den anderen wenig
bis gar nicht. Habe ich dich richtig
verstanden? Nach dem, was ich lese beim
RKI hilft es zumindest der Verbreitung.
Die Wahrscheinlichkeit der Verbreitung ist
geringer durch viele geimpfte
Menschen. Das sagt das RKI aktuell zumindest
auf der Webseite. Ihr sagt, dass es eben
nicht nur eine persönliche Entscheidung.
-Führt das mal aus.
-Ein Satz noch zu Lutz. Ich glaube, das ist
eines der großen
Missverständnisse, auch der Pandemie. Spalten tun nicht
die Regeln, spalten tun Menschen,
die sich gegen die Solidarität entscheiden
und in einer Pandemie, ich glaube,
das haben wir alle inzwischen verstanden,
wie auch in vielen anderen Teilen
des gesellschaftlichen Zusammenlebens, gibt
es diese Entscheidung nur für mich,
nicht. Wenn ich in einer Gesellschaft lebe,
dann muss ich auch ein bisschen
schauen, was meine Entscheidungen mit den anderen
machen. Und das kam zum Beispiel in deiner
Begründung in keinster Weise vor.
Guck in andere Länder. Israel,
Island zum Beispiel. Die haben wahnsinnig hohe
Quoten. Die Inzidenz sind total hoch.
Es ist einfach nicht so. Ich habe gestern,
als ich mich noch mal
vorbereitet habe, Herrn Professor Dr. Kekulé,
Herrn Professor Dr. Drosten noch mal
angehört. Diese ganzen langen Podcasts mir
angehört. Herr Professor Dr. sagt,
es sind zwei Monate. Zwei Monate hat man
diesen vollständigen Impfschutz.
Entschuldige, da kann ich keinen solchen
Unterschied zwischen Geimpften und Ungeimpften
ziehen, wenn der Impfschutz so
schlecht ist. Das will keiner
aussprechen, weil das ist ja die einzige Strategie,
die die Regierung gerade vorgibt. Es ist
impfen, impfen, impfen. Aber wie gut
die Impfung funktioniert, wenn wir um Solidarität
reden, die funktioniert dann
nicht gut. Die macht einen
guten Selbstschutz, mehr nicht.
So Elke, jetzt müssen wir mal ganz
kurz medizinisch werden. Ich fasse noch mal
ganz kurz zusammen. Es gibt
verschiedene Warten. Ich glaube, wir können uns aber
darauf einigen: Die Wahrscheinlichkeit
der Ausbreitung des Virus wird gemindert,
wenn möglichst viele Menschen
geimpft sind. Sind wir uns da einig?
-Da sind wir uns einig.
-Ja, bedingt.
-Nein!
-Das ist ja wichtig, dass wir wenigstens
-diesen Grundkonsens haben.
-Bedingt dahingehend, sind wir auf
individueller Ebene oder auf Bevölkerungsebene?
Das ist das, Miriam hat
es ja gerade angesprochen, dass es vor allem
ein Individualschutz ist. Also
die idee, die man mal hatte und die wunderbar
wäre, hätte sie funktioniert,
dass man eine Herdenimmunität
erreichen kann-
-Das stimmt alles gar nicht.
--der hängen wir noch nach und politische
Entscheidungen werden aktuell immer
noch von dieser Illusion getragen, dass das so
-sei.
-Aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit der Weitergabe
sinkt mit einer Impfung auch gesamtgesellschaftlich
gesehen.
Dem würdest du doch trotzdem
zustimmen, auch wenn es kein 100 Prozent Schutz ist,
aber die Wahrscheinlichkeit sinkt. Oder nicht?
Das wäre jetzt natürlich schwierig,
also diesen Konsens bräuchten wir,
sonst können wir gar nicht weiter diskutieren.
Aber das ist ja die Grundlage von allem.
Das ist ja das, warum die Fronten so
-verhärtet sind. Aber-
-Der ist reduziert. Aber die Frage ist, in
-welchem Maße.
-Genau: Er ist reduziert. In welchem Maße
-ist unklar.
-Darf ich da was dazu sagen? Weil da gibt
-es Daten dazu.
-Lassen wir doch mal Elke hören.
Also so ein paar Daten und Fakten:
Die Impfung schützt die ersten zwei Monate
gleichmäßig vor der Erkrankung und vor der Weitergabe
der Erkrankung. Nach zwei
Monaten beginnt es, dass dieser Impfschutz
langsam weniger wird. Der ist nach sechs
Monaten immer noch gut
vorhanden, wenn derjenige, der geimpft ist,
-keine Immundeffizienz hat.
-Da gibt es auch keinen Dissens. So und
-jetzt?
-Das heißt aber nicht, dass nach zwei
Monaten die Impfung nichts mehr
bringt. Das heißt auch nicht, dass nach zwei
Monaten die Impfung nicht mehr
vor Weitergabe schützt. Laut dem Dossier
vom RKI, dass die Impfungen von Beginn
der Impfserie 27. 12. bis zum 31. 8.
ausgewertet hat - das Dossier
ist im September erschienen - reduziert
dieser Impfschutz zumindest bei Corminaty,
also bei den mRNA-Impfstoffen,
die Viruslast im Körper, die weitergegeben
werden kann auf 25 Prozent. Das heißt,
wenn ich geimpft bin, nur noch 25
Prozent so ansteckend wie jemand, der ungeimpft
ist und der zur gleichen
Zeit infiziert wurde.
Und dann deine Antwort auf Lutz.
Lutz sagt, er stimmt dir zu. Er sagt:
Ich glaube dir, aber ich finde,
wir sollten jetzt die Regeln trotzdem so
öffnen, dass man sagt: Ihr könnt euch
alle impfen, wenn ihr wollt und dann könnt
ihr auch wieder
feiern gehen. Was sagst du?
Ihr könnt euch alle impfen, wenn ihr wollt
und könnt dann auch feiern gehen. Das wäre
meine Antwort dazu, weil derjenige,
der ungeimpft ist und ich bin im Augenblick
sehr unsicher, ob ich nicht lieber
meine Maske anziehe, da Ungeimpfte im Raum sind
und ich die nicht
zusätzlich gefährden möchte.
Ich bin getestet
natürlich, sonst wäre ich ja nicht hier.
Nein, ich möchte jemand ungeimpften
nicht gefährden, deswegen verlange ich von dir
nicht, dass du die Maske aufzieht.
Aber ich würde aus meinem persönlichen
-Empfinden-
-Aber das ist doch ihre Entscheidung.
Das ist doch genau das, dass auch ein Herr
Lauterbach das Gefühl hat, er müsste alle
Menschen vor allem schützen. Ich kann
auch individuell entscheiden. Ich war
auch reiten am Wochenende. Ich bin mit dem Auto
hierher gefahren. Ich war teilweise
-nicht angeschnallt.
-Ich möchte nicht dich schützen, sondern
ich möchte denjenigen schützen,
der deinen Intensivplatz bekommen könnte
und eine Krebs Operation
bekommen könnte. Den möchte ich schützen.
Aber dann kann ich auch nicht
mehr reiten, nicht mehr Ski fahren-
Das sind wir weit
davon entfernt, dass wir alle.
-Wir müssen uns die Risiken-
-Jessica darf mal ausreden.
War jemand von euch schon mal auf einer Intensivstation
mit ECMO? War jemand
-von euch-
-Nein, weil wir dort alle nicht hingehören.
Aber wenn jemand selbstbestimmt
entscheidet, dass er zum Beispiel mit 150
Sachen einen Berg runter fährt mit seinen
Skiern, dann ist das seine persönliche
Entscheidung und wenn er im Krankenhaus
landet, kann ich es auch nicht
unterbinden. Das heißt, was maßen
wir uns an, dass wir den Menschen zunehmend
vorschreiben, was sie zu machen
haben, was sie nicht zu machen haben,
wenn sie das eigene Risiko
eingehen. Ich sehe das Argument mit den Betten,
dass die irgendwann belegt sind. Und dann
muss man wahrscheinlich auch die Maßnahmen
-wieder verschärfen.
-Wenn die Betten belegt sind und die
Maßnahmen zu verschärfen, sind
etwa drei bis vier Wochen zu spät.
Wir sterben nach wie vor an Herz-Kreislauf-Krankheiten.
Wollen
wir jetzt allen Leuten vorschreiben,
dass sie dreimal die Woche Sport machen,
sich vegan ernähren? Also im Prinzip,
das Thema war ja schon vor Corona da,
dass die Intensivstationen
viel zu tun haben.
Ich glaube, dass wir einfach zu wenig
oder dass die Bevölkerung zu wenig von dem Leid
mitbekommen hat,
das Covid selber anstellt.
-Das glaube ich nicht.
-Ich würde mal gerne von dir wissen, Erik,
-wie verfolgst du gerade diese Diskussion?
-Ich verfolge die Situation gerade so, dass
ich nicht ganz verstehen kann, also
das Argument von Lutz, weil er sagt zwar
auf der einen Seite: Jeder hat jetzt
das Angebot gehabt. Wie lange wollen wir noch
die Maßnahme ertragen? Sie sind
natürlich komplett unpopulär. Bin ich auch bei dir,
aber ist eine unpopuläre Maßnahme,
die uns davor schützt in eine Situation
zu geraten. Wir sind noch nach wie vor in einer Pandemie.
Wir haben zwar den Satz:
Jeder hat ein Angebot, aber wir haben
leider zu viele, die gesagt haben: Nein,
-ich nehme dieses Angebot nicht an.
-Aber das ist auch nicht richtig, wenn man-
-Lass ihn kurz mal kurz ausreden!
-Und mein Problem, was ich habe, ist zum
Beispiel als Club oder in meinem Fall
als Bar würde ich jetzt auch nicht sagen,
ich mache jetzt 3G als Familien-Restaurant
oder als Supermarkt. Bin ich auch dagegen.
Aber ich habe eine Nachtbar, die bis 5/6
Uhr morgens offen hat und ich bin ein Ort
der Ansteckung. So, wenn ich jetzt
zugestehen würde, dass ich sage: Okay,
es können auch Ungeimpfte
einfach reinkommen-
-Getestet, aber!
-Ne, der Test hat ja noch ein nächstes
Problem. Ich kann ja negativ
getestet sein, aber trotzdem schon längst hoch
infektiös, weil er erst nach drei
oder vier Tagen anschlägt. Also ich habe ja
immer noch diese Latenz
dazwischen. Ich möchte, dass wir das Problem
in dem wir uns befinden,
gesamtgesellschaftlich, da möchte
ich einfach raus. Ich möchte über
Corona nicht mehr reden, ich will das nicht
künstlich verlängern. Und wenn ich als Bar
sage, ich mache 3G, dann verlängere
ich dieses Problem, in dem wir uns
gerade befinden, um noch vielleicht ein viertel
Jahr und das möchte ich einfach
nicht. Ich möchte, dass es verschwindet.
So und genau darum geht es. Um Maßnahmen,
die Geimpfte und Ungeimpfte
unterschiedlich
treffen. Jetzt kommt Jessica dran.
Wir bringen hier ganz viel
durcheinander. Sehe ich gerade. Also es ist nicht
das Virus, das dazu führt, dass wir diese Beschränkung
haben, sondern es sind
politische Entscheidungen. Mein Statement
dazu ist ganz klar: Entweder es gibt
eine Testpflicht für alle, vor diesem Hintergrund,
dass auch Geimpfte
nach wie vor zum Infektionsgeschehen,
und zwar nicht unerheblich, beigetragen
oder man hebt eben auch die Zugangsbeschränkungen
für alle auf.
Aber diese Ungleichbehandlung,
die ist am Ende des Tages willkürlich
und daher schnellstmöglich zu beenden.
Wir sehen das, wenn wir in andere Länder
schauen. Schweden zum Beispiel ist von Anfang
an einen ganz anderen Weg gegangen.
Dänemark, Niederlande,
Großbritannien haben geöffnet, da sind die Inzidenzen
höher. Das sind auch die Krankenhaus
Einlieferung höher.
-Die Toten vor allem.
-Das ist aber eine politische Entscheidung.
So zu tun, als ob es quasi
Naturgesetz wäre, als wäre es die Schwerkraft.
Im Diskurs wird es so behandelt, als kann
das nur so sein. Das ist falsch. Es ist
eine politische Entscheidung, die genau
so anders lauten könnte. Die könnte genauso
heißen: Wir heben jetzt alle Maßnahmen
auf. Jeder hat ein Impfangebot bekommen ab
12 Jahren, kann es annehmen, kann es lassen.
Eine systemische Überlastung droht
-nicht mehr.
-Lasst uns mal bitte versuchen, an einem
Punkt zu bleiben. Wir haben
jetzt angefangen mit 2G-Regelungen
und 3G-Regelungen. Damit sind wir eingestiegen
und ich weiß, du hast schon
gegen viele Maßnahmen auch geklagt,
mit mehr oder weniger großem Erfolg. Da ging
es um die sinnlosen Maßnahmen wie 1,5
km Regelung. Es ging um Ausgangssperren
und jetzt geht es unter anderem auch um die 2G-Frage.
Ich weiß, bei 2G kommst du
aus dem Kopfschütteln nicht mehr raus.
Sag doch mal ganz kurz, aus rechtlicher Sicht,
-warum?
-Auf den Punkt gebracht: Infektionsschutz
ist Gefahrenabwehr. Das heißt, ich muss
schauen, wer potenziell gefährdet und,
wobei wir uns da offensichtlich nicht
ganz einig werden hier, aus meiner Sicht,
wie ich das Ganze beurteile, ist es eben
so, dass Geimpfte ebenso relevant
zum Infektionsgeschehen, von mir
aus vermindert, aber immer noch relevant,
beitragen. Und alleine deswegen ist es eben
nicht gerechtfertigt, quasi Geimpfte
zu privilegieren und zu sagen, wir behandeln
sie so, als würden sie niemanden
gefährden oder so gut wie niemanden
gefährden. Das ist nämlich einfach nicht
-der Fall.
-Friedemann, kannst du das nachvollziehen?
Also ich gehe sehr, sehr gerne
einen Schritt nach vorne. Einerseits,
weil ich mich selber gewundert habe,
wie konfrontativ es wird. Das hätte ich gar
nicht gedacht. Und zweitens, weil ich immer
gerne auf Expert*innen höre und du
bist Juristin. Und ich dachte mir
schon, dass du sehr, sehr gute Argumente hast
für deinen Standpunkt. Ich würde aber
vielleicht noch mal versuchen, eins größer
drauf zu schauen. Wir leben nun
mal in einer liberalen Demokratie,
in einer Gesellschaft. Die ist enorm
darauf angewiesen, dass wir solidarisch
sind und dass wir gewisse Regeln der Solidarität
auch aushandeln. Demokratisch,
transparent, in einem Parlament und sie in Gesetze
gießen. Das ist nie perfekt.
Und ich gebe euch absolut
Recht, dass es sehr gute Argumente
auch gegen eine 2G-Regelung gibt.
Und ich würde auch noch mal betonen,
dass ich der erste wäre, der gegen eine Impfpflicht
auf die Straße geht,
weil das ist mit unseren Werten nicht
zu vereinbaren. Wir müssen aber - und gerade
in einer Situation, die für uns alle
neu ist wie einer globalen Pandemie - manchmal
Absprachen treffen und Regelungen
treffen, die nicht perfekt sind
und gegen die es Argumente gibt. So
wie wir, wenn wir, einfacher Vergleich,
am Straßenverkehr teilnehmen wollen,
gewisse Regeln beachten müssen. Die sind
vielleicht nicht für alle sofort
einleuchtend, aber sie haben sich so ganz
gut erwiesen. Wir haben nur leider
keine Zeit, über Jahre und Jahrzehnte
herauszufinden, ob eine Gurtpflicht
gut ist oder nicht, die glaube
ich in Deutschland erst 1969 gegen großen
Widerstand eingeführt wurde und sie glaube
ich, heute uns allen sinnvoll
erscheint. Und ich finde im Zweifelsfall muss man
die ein oder andere Kröte
schlucken, solange es zum Beispiel nicht
an die Unversehrtheit des Körpers
geht, um das, was wir ja alle schätzen
und was wir alle enorm vermisst
haben, nämlich gesellschaftliches Zusammenleben
wieder möglichst sicher, nicht
100 Prozent sicher, das gibt es nicht,
möglichst sicher
wieder einführen zu können.
Du hast es geschafft. Manche
sind nach vorne gegangen und Miriam hat
-eine Antwort.
-Ja, ich habe auch gar keine Lust zu
streiten mit euch. Du hast mehrere
Dinge gesagt: Parlamentarisch, da bin
ich auch dafür. Wir haben aber nach wie vor diese epidemischen
Notlage, die dazu
führt, dass es eben nicht mehr
komplett im Parlament alles besprochen wird,
sondern ein Herr Spahn Beschlüsse
machen kann. Und ich bin sehr dafür,
dass es demokratischer wird und dass mehr
diskutiert wird, weil das passiert gerade
zu wenig. Und wenn du sagst, das ist
dieses blöde Beispiel, was mir auch immer
an den Kopf geworfen wird mit der Anschnallpflicht.
Ich schnall mich
auch an. Ich bin auch dafür, dass man
sich anschnallt. Aber ich würde jetzt nicht
an der roten Ampel aussteigen,
wenn ich sehe, der ist nicht angeschnallt,
klopfen und sagen: Sagen Sie mal,
schnallen Sie sich bitte an, weil ich habe
irgendwie Angst, dass Sie sonst auf der Intensivstation
landen und mir dann einen
Platz eventuell wegnehmen oder jemand
anderen. Und das passiert aber gerade
mit den Ungeimpften, finde ich, dass man
dieses Anklopfen macht. Und woher nimmt
man dieses Recht und die körperliche
Unversehrtheit, solange es nicht
an die körperliche
Unversehrtheit geht. Genau da bin ich auch dafür.
Aber tatsächlich wissen wir nicht,
ob diese Impfung nicht doch
-an meine körperliche Unversehrtheit geht.
-Darf ich einen Satz sagen?
-Klar.
-Ich finde es schön, wie du darauf
eingegangen bist. Ich finde, wenn man
sich in der Situation gegen die Impfung
entscheidet und das Recht sollte
man haben, muss man mit dem Anklopfen
-an die Scheibe im Zweifelsfall leben.
-Also ich ich würde dagegen argumentieren
und sagen, es geht um Verhältnismäßigkeit
und bis vor ein paar Monaten war
ich ein totaler Unterstützer und bin es nach wie vor,
die Leute sollen sich impfen
lassen. Wir haben sogar Impfennächte
veranstaltet in Berlin. Wir haben wirklich
eine Kampagne dafür gemacht, weil wir eben
auch glauben, so wie du auch: Wir müssen
wieder zur Normalität zurückkommen.
Impfen ist dafür wichtig. Jetzt sind wir aber
an einen Punkt gekommen, wo ich glaube,
jetzt müssen wir über
die Verhältnismäßigkeit sprechen und auch wieder
selbstbestimmt Leute entscheiden
lassen. Und ich glaube nicht, dass wir die Entscheidung
den Menschen abnehmen können.
Und ich fange auch nicht an, jetzt über
Prozente diskutieren, ob das jetzt bei 82,
83, 85 Pozent möglich ist, weil da bin
ich auch eher bei euch, dass die Gefahr,
dass wir doch nicht zu einer Herdenimmunität
kommen, einfach zu groß
ist. Und dann müssen wir eben
anders mit der Pandemie umgehen.
Aber du hast ja ein Kriterium
gehabt, du hast irgendwann gesagt, wir haben 10
bis 15 Prozent Ungeimpfte
mögliche Clubgäste und das ist für euch dann
-die Grenze gewesen.
-Die Clubs sind wieder offen unter
2G-Regelung und wir lassen aber eben
einen großen Teil unserer Community außen vor.
Als Gesellschaft ist es aber
unsere Aufgabe, wir sehen das sozusagen
als Clubs, Menschen
zusammenzubringen und eben auch in dieser Pandemiezeit
und Post-Pandemiezeit die Gesellschaft
zusammenzuführen. Das geht eben nicht,
wenn wir ihnen die Pistole auf die Brust
setzen und sagen es geht nur,
wenn ihr geimpft seid. Dann
sag ich lieber, lasst euch testen,
dass ihr niemand anders gefährdet.
Aber ihr könnt selbst ein persönliches Risiko
eingehen, das ist eure persönliche
Entscheidung und die kann ich euch
-auch nicht abnehmen.
-Also für ihn ist die Grenze einfach
erreicht. Der Punkt, an dem er sagt,
okay, jetzt, jetzt sind wir schon so weit.
Es gibt so wenige Ungeimpfte,
zumindest bei dir und bei dir. Für dich wäre
die Grenze jetzt erreicht, wo du
sagst, okay, wir können jetzt diese Maßnahmen,
vor allem diese Unterscheidung
zwischen geimpft und ungeimpft, können wir jetzt
sein lassen. Wo ist denn für euch
der Punkt? Also ab wann sagt man,
jetzt treffen wir keine
Unterscheidung mehr, jetzt machen wir Dänemarkmodell
-alles auf.
-Wenn wir die Impfquoten haben wie dort.
-Also 85 Prozent der Erwachsenen.
-Man darf ja bei Dänemark und Portugal und
diesen ganzen Vergleichesländern nicht
vergessen, dass die zu einer Zeit geöffnet
haben, oder speziell England, das war
im Sommer oder weit über Monate zurück jetzt.
Und wenn wir jetzt das im Herbst
machen, wo die Inzidenzen
aufgrund der Saisonalität sowieso
steigen werden, dann ist das vielleicht der völlig
falsche Zeitpunkt. Also ich bin da komplett
bei dir, diese Grenze, ich möchte
sie auch unbedingt überschreiten.
Ich möchte niemanden vor der Bar abweisen
müssen und möchte sagen, du bist
ungeimpft, du bist nicht geimpft. Du Ja,
du Nein, das möchte ich nicht.
Ganz im Gegenteil. Aber ich bin gezwungen,
das zu machen, weil wenn ich jetzt
sage als Club, zum Beispiel, oder als Bar,
ich mache jetzt hier 3G, ich akzeptiere
diesen Test, der hier mir nachts um zwei
von fünf besoffenen Typen vor die Nase
gehalten wird, dann weiß ich ganz genau,
das ist gefaked. Es ist
nicht richtig. Es ist falsch.
Was ist deine Sorge? Was glaubst
du? Du hast Angst vor der Überlastung
-der Intensivstation?
-Die Sorge ist nicht das, was bei mir
individuell im Club oder in der Bar
passiert, sondern wenn wir jetzt
gesamtgesellschaftlich sagen, okay,
auch nachts in Clubs in Berlin oder München
oder Köln können jetzt 3G-Modus
gefahren werden, dann haben wir das Problem,
dass wenn sich jemand mit einem Test
dort anmeldet, und sagt, er ist negativ,
er trotzdem längst hochgradig
infektiös sein kann. Und wenn er dann sich
in diesem Kontext bewegt, wir hatten
Ischgl vor Augen, wir wissen doch
mittlerweile, was mit dem Virus
passiert und wie es sich verbreitet. Und dann ist
genau der Kontext, in dem wir uns
befinden, dann der Faktor, der dafür
sorgt, dass wir die ganze Inzidenz
wieder nach oben schießen. Und deswegen bin
ich auch der Meinung, dass das asozial
ist, zu sagen, ich mache hier 3G,
weil die Gesellschaft hat mich ja
auch über die 8 Monate Schließzeit hinweg
-getragen, die haben ja Gelder bezahlt-
-Ja, und auch die, die nicht geimpft sind.
- und wenn ich jetzt künstlich
dazu beitrage, die Inzidenz wieder
hochzutreiben, dann
ist das kontraproduktiv.
Jessica, kannst du das nachvollziehen,
dass er sagt, er erwartet auch die Grenze.
Er will gerne den Punkt erreichen, wo man
das alles, wo man Maßnahmen abschaffen
kann. Aber für ihn ist aus verschiedenen
Gründen dieser Punkt noch nicht erreicht.
Bis dahin brauchen wir diese Unterscheidung
zwischen geimpft
-und ungeimpft. Kannst das nachvollziehen?
-Ich verstehe die wirtschaftliche Not. Ich
glaube aber auch, dass ist ein schlechtes
Zeichen ist an diejenigen. Du hast
auch gesagt, es muss eine freie
Entscheidung sein. Auch du hast gesagt,
es muss eine freie Entscheidung sein,
hast gesagt, man muss es parlamentarisch
bestimmen. Muss man. Was wir jetzt
aber erleben, ist eine faktische Impfpflicht.
Ich hab jetzt die Wahl, mich
ausschließen zu lassen aus der Gesellschaft,
oder ich habe die Wahl, mich impfen
zu lassen. Das ist keine richtige Wahl,
letzten Endes. Das heißt, die ehrliche
Variante wäre, dafür würde
ich auch plädieren, wenn man meint,
man muss das machen, dann soll man es ehrlich
machen und dann macht man eine Impfpflicht
und dann werden wir die rechtlich
überprüfen lassen.
So können wir das nicht.
Ganz kurz, ich dachte, du sagts
gleich, die Impfpflicht durch die Hintertür.
Du hast jetzt gesagt faktische
Impfpflicht. Ich glaube, uns verbindet
eines professionell, wir arbeiten mit Sprache
und ich glaube, du wirst dir genau
überlegt haben, warum du es so nennst.
Ich würde widersprechen. Eine Impfpflicht ist
eine Impfpflicht und ein unterschiedlicher
Zugang zu ganz bestimmten Bereichen,
der sich ja auch nicht auf die gesamte
Gesellschaft schaltet, du darfst ja
auch noch aus dem Haus gehen.
Niemand verbietet dir noch rauszugehen.
-Das ist nett.
-Aber das muss man einmal festhalten. Man
-kann ja auch-
-Ich lass dich ausreden, dann würde ich
-gerne etwas dazu sagen.
-Ja, sehr gerne. Man kann ja auch nicht so
tun, als wären die Ungeimpften jetzt
im Gefängnis, sondern es gibt bestimmte
Räume, gesellschaftliche Räume, wo wir uns
gegenseitig schützen wollen, wo wir uns
begegnen wollen, zum Beispiel die Clubs.
Und da kann man unterschiedlich
entscheiden, welches Risiko wir eingehen.
Deswegen finde ich es ganz wichtig,
noch mal festzuhalten, es ist auch keine
Impfpflicht durch die Hintertür.
-Miriam, fühlst du dich wie im Gefängnis?
-Ich fühle mich nicht im Gefängnis, weil
ich lebe auf dem Land und da kann
ich sowieso machen, was ich möchte. Aber
es geht darum, dass es auch Berufe
betrifft. Ich kenne
Kindergarten-Pädagoginnen, die ihren
Job gekündigt haben oder worden sind.
Ich kenne Krankenschwestern, die ihren
Job haben fallen lassen. Schlecht
in der Pandemie, wenn Krankenhauspersonal
kündigt.
-Schauspieler*innen?
-Ich kenne auch Schauspieler und
Schauspielerinnen, die gerade nicht
arbeiten können, weil sie ungeimpft sind.
Das heißt, ich glaube als Geimpfter
ist es leicht zu sagen, ja, es geht ja
nur um den Club oder um so was. Es geht
wirklich um viel mehr. Und das kann man
nicht ignorieren oder wegleugnen,
weil das passiert einfach gerade.
Also aus meiner Beratungspraxis
kann ich dir sagen, das betrifft eben nicht
nur das Freizeitverhalten, es betrifft
die Arbeit zum Beispiel. Da gibt
es ein Geschäftsessen. Dann ist sie,
okay, was mache ich jetzt? Es ist 2G. Wie komme
ich jetzt? Ich will mich auch nicht
outen, weil ich habe Angst, meine Karriere
zu gefährden. Solche Fälle gibt es.
Sie sind real. Die passieren jetzt nicht
nur ein oder zweimal, sie sind
real. Hochschulen, Zugang über 3G. In meinem
Bundesland müssen die Tests selbst
bezahlt werden. Keine Selbsttest möglich. Das ist
nicht leistbar, letzten Endes. Also
zu sagen, na ja, man kann doch und das ist
doch eigentlich auch gar keine
richtige Pflicht. Da macht man es sich zu einfach.
Lasst uns doch mal ganz kurz bei dem Punkt
bleiben. Miriam hat ja aufgeworfen,
es geht eben nicht nur darum, ob ich mal
in den Club gehen kann und feiern.
Bei manchen Menschen geht es um die Existenz.
Es geht darum, dass ich meinen
Beruf vielleicht nicht mehr ausüben
kann, weil ich mich dafür entschieden habe,
mich nicht impfen zu lassen, aus welchen Gründen
auch immer. Vielleicht sind
es sogar die komplett falschen
Gründe. Kann ja sein. Ist es dann trotzdem
gerecht, den Leuten zu sagen,
sorry, dann darfst halt nicht mehr arbeiten?
Es wird der Punkt kommen, da können
die wieder arbeiten. Aber genau
in der jetzigen Situation, in der Pandemie
eben nicht. Darüber reden wir doch.
Das heißt, vorübergehend nimmst du das in Kauf,
als Kröte, die man schlucken muss?
Also ich würde mich nicht jetzt in eine Situation
setzen und sagen, du darfst
den Job jetzt nicht mehr machen.
Das möchte ich mir jetzt nicht anmaßen,
-aber ich möchte auch-
-Andererseits darf ich doch als Arbeitgeber
überhaupt nicht fragen, ob derjenige
geimpft ist oder nicht.
Natürlich nicht, aber
es passiert ja trotzdem.
Und wenn ich fragen darf, darf
derjenige, der ungeimpft ist, lügen?
Genau, und da sage
ich, das ist das Problem-
Weil es arbeitsrechtlich
keine Konsequenz hat.
Da hast du recht, aber das Problem
ist dann, wenn wirklich so was wie ein-
Es gibt viele, die auf Veranstaltungen,
auch auf 2G Veranstaltungen gehen quasi
und dann müssten sie sich outen. Und wie machen
das die Leute? Sind dann krank
oder ähnliches. Das sind die Dinge, die mir
gesagt werden, weil in dem Moment muss
ich mich ja outen. Oder ich habe
ein Arbeitsessen mit dem Chef, dann muss
ich auch irgendeinen Nachweis haben.
Das ist das Problem, dass man das nur bedingt
tatsächlich geheim halten
kann, auch wenn es rechtlich so ist.
Und ich finde auch interessant,
dass Sie mir vorschlagen, ich soll lügen.
-Ich möchte doch gar nicht lügen müssen.
-Kann ich bitte noch einmal eins
klarstellen? Die 2G Regelung ist auf jeden
Fall eine Impfpflicht durch die Hintertür
und das ist auch okay so. Ich finde,
man soll den Druck erhöhen, dass sich
möglichst viele Menschen impfen lassen.
Da bin ich total bei euch. Aber das kann man
auch nur ein gewissen
Zeitraum machen. Man muss sich angucken,
wie die Impfbereitschaft ist und wenn die irgendwann
ins Stocken gerät oder gar
nicht mehr da ist, dann muss man
den Menschen auch ihre Entscheidung dann
auch überlassen und dann soll man es ihnen
immer noch nicht so einfach machen.
Von mir aus kann man auch für den Test
bezahlen, wenn man dann einen Schnelltest
oder einen PCR Test macht und möglichst günstig,
dass auch die Teilhabe wieder
möglich ist und es sich jeder
leisten kann. Aber wir sind an dem Punkt,
wo wir sagen müssen, Leute, wir können
nicht Leute einfach außen vorlassen.
Und wenn sie sich einfach nicht
impfen lassen wollen und ein Risiko,
ein persönliches Risiko eingehen
möchten, dann müssen sie auch das machen lassen.
Damit hast du offenbar Friedemann
überzeugt. Du bist gleich dran. Du bist
-auch gleich dran.
-Ein Stück weit, weil ich den Punkt der
Teilhabe und gerade bei sozial
schwachen Menschen total, völlig verstehe.
Ich glaube, da sind wir relativ nah
beieinander und ich würde auch noch mal,
wäre noch mal daran interessiert, zu diskutieren,
wie bekommt man die, die sich
noch nicht geimpft haben, die leicht
erreichbar wären, aus welchen Gründen
auch immer, weil sie vielleicht nicht
so gut Deutsch sprechen, weil sie ihnen nicht
den Zugang zu Information haben, weil sie vielleicht
auch einfach den Ernst der Lage
in den letzten anderthalb Jahren
noch nicht so verstanden haben. Und wenn man
es anders kommunizieren würde, würde
man sie kriegen. Ich finde, darüber reden
wir immer noch zu wenig. Und da muss
natürlich noch sehr viel passieren.
Wir reden aber auch sehr wenig über
Leute, die in den letzten anderthalb Jahren große
Lasten getragen haben. Leute, die eben
sehr gefährdet waren, die Immunekrankungen
haben, die sogenannten Armen
und Schwachen, die wir schützen müssen
und Leute, die sich vielleicht haben
impfen lassen, auch vielleicht mit einem
bisschen Bauchweh. Ich bekomme
auch nicht gern eine Spritze in den Arm,
von der ich natürlich nie 1000
Prozent weiß, was sie ausmacht. So, jetzt bin
ich ein Kind von Pharmazeuten. Das heißt,
ich konnte mit meinen Eltern ganz gut
darüber diskutieren. Was bedeutet
zum Beispiel ein beschleunigtes
Zulassungsverfahren? Die haben
mich dahingehend auch beruhigen können.
Und trotzdem glaube ich, gibt es in dem Land
Millionen Leute, die sich nicht haben
impfen lassen, weil sie Bock auf eine Spritze
haben oder weil sie 100 Prozent
davon überzeugt sind, sondern auch aus Solidarität.
Und über diese reden
-wir nicht.
-Entschuldige, ich-
Ganz, ganz kurz. Das heißt, nur um es klarzustellen,
du bist sofort dran.
Das heißt, du bleibst dabei,
Impfen ist ein Akt der Solidarität.
-Ja.
-Und jetzt kommt Miriam.
Ganz direkt darauf, weil ich glaube
auch, dass sich sehr viele Menschen haben impfen
lassen, aber für mich nicht aus Solidarität,
sondern um wieder normal
leben zu können. Um zurückzukommen zu dem Leben,
wie es vor Corona war, so wie du
das vorher formuliert hast. Man
will doch einfach, dass es vorbei ist. Aber
mein Punkt ist, ich glaube nicht,
dass es die Impfung dazu braucht. Es ist
eine politische Entscheidung, diese Pandemie
zu beenden oder nicht zu beenden.
Was meint ihr eigentlich? Ist das Ganze
überhaupt eine Frage der Solidarität?
Und wenn nicht, welche Frage ist
es denn dann? Schreibt es uns gerne
in die Kommentare. Und jetzt
kommt Jessica dran.
Wenn ich da nur ergänzen darf, du
hast es im Prinzip so dargestellt als -
und das ist auch das, was in der Öffentlichkeit
so kolportiert wird -
als seine Entscheidung gegen die Impfung.
Entweder ist- also irgendwas stimmt
mit dem Menschen nicht. Er ist
entweder dumm oder versteht kein,
versteht vielleicht kein Deutsch
oder er ist unsolidarisch. Aber das finde
ich schwierig, weil ich persönlich,
meine Haltung ist, jeder darf selbst
entscheiden, Risikoabwägung,
Kosten-Nutzen-Abwägung machen, ob er sich
impfen lässt oder nicht. Und das habe
ich nicht zu bewerten.
Ehrlich gesagt interessiert es mich
auch nicht so wahnsinnig brennend, warum sich
jemand dafür oder dagegen
entscheidet. Deswegen würde ich mir das nicht anmaßen
und stimme dir im ersten Teil total
zu. Der zweite Teil, finde ich interessant,
weil der glaube ich oft in der Pandemie
jetzt auch falsch verstanden wurde,
auch in anderen politischen
Diskussionen. Natürlich maßen wir uns als Gesellschaft
an ganz, ganz vielen Stellen an,
Verhalten in Anführungsstrichen zu bewerten,
indem wir es zum Beispiel unter Strafe
stellen, oder indem wir gewisse Regeln
aufrechterhalten. Und, um beim
Beispiel Verkehr zu bleiben, wenn ich da rausgehe,
unterwerfe ich mich einem
komplizierten und sehr, sehr dicken Set an Regeln,
damit ich am Verkehr teilnehmen kann,
um was zu ermöglichen? Halbwegs sicherer,
friedlicher Verkehr und Mobilität, weil es ein hohes
Gut ist. Das heißt, der letzte
Satz, da muss ich widersprechen.
Wir bewerten und wir stufen ein, die ganze
-Zeit. Und das bedeutet Zusammenleben.
-Stimmt, aber mit Regeln und die gibt es
nicht. Dann macht man eine Impfpflicht.
Also ich bin dafür, dass man mit offenen
Karten spielt, und dann gibt es eben
eine Pflicht und dann kann ich dagegen
vorgehen. Jetzt gibt es die nicht
und es gibt diesen sozialen Druck.
Diejenigen sagen jetzt, wir haben
uns eingeschränkt, wir haben uns den Pieks
geben lassen, damit alle, die ganze
Gesellschaft, da wieder rauskommen.
Ihr wollt das nicht machen und das empfinden
manche als unsolidarisch.
Erkennst du an, dass es auch für dich
hilfreich sein kann, dass die Mehrheit
-der Bevölkerung sich hat impfen lassen?
-Nein, ich, tatsächlich-
00:35:43,189 --> 00:35:43,089
-Ja!
-Politisch würde ich sagen, ja.
-Auf Gesamtebene, ja. Aber ich persönlich-
-Aber auch medizinisch ist die Gefahr, dass
eben viele Menschen ins Krankenhaus
kommen, deutlich geringer, wenn die Leute
-geimpft sind.
-Okay, gut, da bin ich einig. Aber ich habe
niemanden, ich persönlich, Miriam,
habe niemanden darum gebeten, sich für mich
impfen zu lassen, weil ich, wie gesagt
denke, ich würde dieses Virus überleben.
Und wenn nicht, dann habe ich mich
geirrt, dann war es meine Entscheidung.
-Der Friedemann wollte darauf antworten.
-Ich möchte wirklich nur einen Satz, weil
es um meine Impfung ging. Bei mir
persönlich war es eine Mischung
-aus Gründen, tatsächlich.
-Das musst du auch gar nicht offenlegen.
Aber auch der solidarische Gedanke und ich hätte
einfach nicht damit leben können,
ob es dann passiert oder nicht, aber
dass ich auch ein wandelndes Risiko bin,
einerseits selber schwer zu erkranken,
weil es erkranken leider auch gesunde,
mittelalte Männer und zweitens
jemand anderen vielleicht anzustecken,
weil das durchaus auch immer
wieder vorkommt. Und ich hätte
auch einer Krankenschwester oder einer Ärztin
nicht ins Gesicht schauen können
und sagen können, na ja, aber
das Risiko bin ich eben eingegangen.
Aber Grundrechte sind dafür da, auch die Minderheit
zu schützen. Die Grundrechte
hören nicht da auf, wo die Angst der anderen
anfängt. Und da müssen wir wieder
hinkommen und ich finde es toll,
dass wir hier ins Gespräch kommen,
auch wenn wir ganz an vielen
Punkten offenbar nicht übereinkommen. Aber
das müssen wir wieder tun. Wir dürfen
uns nicht abschreiben, gegenseitig, und sagen,
nee, der ist asozial, der ist
unsolidarisch, sondern ich möchte euch
verstehen und ich hoffe, dass wir als Gesellschaft
insgesamt wieder miteinander
-ins Reine kommen, sozusagen.
-Es ist ganz interessant, jetzt gab es ja
schon diverse Punkte, wo ihr wirklich
diametral auseinander seid. Aber
dein letzter Vortrag Jessica hat dazu
geführt, dass Grün relativ weit nach vorne
gegangen ist. Du hast nämlich davon
gesprochen, es bringt nichts, wenn wir uns
jetzt mit Häme übergießen, und die einen
sind asozial, die anderen sind sozial.
Da bist du nach vorne
gegangen. Das hat dich überzeugt.
Genau, weil das ist der Punkt, den ich auch so
sehe, dass wir die beiden Lager,
die sich jetzt ja so
herauskristallisieren, wieder versuchen
müssen, über den Dialog
zusammenzuführen. Und dass wir diese gesamte mit Emotionen
aufgeladenen Diskussion, die wir tagtäglich
draußen erleben, einfach wieder
auf einen nüchternen Boden
bringen und vor allem auch die ganzen Sachen
-versachlichen.
-Nämlich wie? Wie bringen wir das auf
nüchternen Boden? Bei Dingen, wo man
offenbar ganz unterschiedlicher Meinung
-ist.
-Das ist schwierig. Es gibt ja die
radikalen Impfgegner, die werden
wir wahrscheinlich nie erreichen. Egal,
mit irgendeinem fachlichen Argument
schon gar nicht mehr und erst recht nicht
mit irgendwelchen Maßnahmen,
wie zum Beispiel 2G oder irgendwelchen
Lohnfortzahlungsgeschichten. Weil das sind
Dinge, die werden die Leute
in dieses Lager versetzen, wo sie sagen,
na jetzt erst recht, also jetzt erst recht
lasse ich mich nicht impfen. Aber es gibt
ja, wie gesagt, noch einen gewissen Anteil
an Leuten, die Politik hat jetzt
auch, muss man auch ganz klar sagen,
nicht geglänzt dabei, das ganze
Problem wirklich so richtig zu kommunizieren,
auch in mehreren Sprachen zu kommunizieren
und das sind, denke ich, noch Potenziale,
die wir haben und da müssen
wir einfach hin.
Könnte es sein, Elke, dass wir, dass diese Diskussion,
diese ganze Sendung eigentlich
obsolet ist, wenn Impfwillige und Impfunwillige
sich die Köpfe einschlagen,
sondern dass man eher diejenigen
erreichen muss, die einfach noch nicht Zugang hatten
zu einer Spritze und dann
wäre das Problem vielleicht gelöst?
Ich denke schon. Ich bin der Meinung,
dass die Erreichbarkeit der Ungeimpften
der Schlüssel ist, um aus der Pandemie
rauszukommen und wirklich
in eine endemische Lage zu kommen.
Wenn wir genug Geimpfte haben, können
wir die wenigen, die jetzt wirklich
militant gegen eine Impfung sich wehren,
wider besseren Wissens oder weil sie nicht
erreichbar sind, dann kann man diejenigen
-einfach mittragen als Gesellschaft.
-Ich frage mal ganz kurz euch: Wie
empfindet ihr diese Debatte? Spaltet
eine solche Debatte? Brauchen wir mehr,
sagen wir mal, mehr Empathie für Impfunwillige?
Würdet ihr sagen, das Ganze
ist hämisch aufgeladen? Ist das ein sinnvoller
Dialog, den wir ja auch hier
führen? Schreibt es uns gerne
in die Kommentare, bevor wir jetzt
in die Kompromissrunde kommen.
Ich weiß, das ist wahnsinnig schwierig,
hier überhaupt einen Kompromiss zu finden.
Ich schlage jetzt mal einen vor und danach
würde ich euch bitten, in euren
Gruppen mal untereinander die Köpfe zusammen
zu stecken, um einen eigenen
Kompromissvorschlag zu konzipieren,
in der Hoffnung, dass sie es schafft,
die anderen ein bisschen mehr zu euch
zu ziehen. Ich sage mal einen
Kompromissvorschlag. Erstes Ziel,
erste Prämisse, unsere Gesellschaft
soll so inklusiv wie möglich sein.
Der Ausschluss von Ungeimpften sollte
also nicht Ziel, sondern höchstens letztes
Mittel sein. Das heißt konkret, und da kommt
jetzt die Einschränkung, 3G schlägt
grundsätzlich 2G, allerdings bei risikobehafteten
Veranstaltungen, so habe
ich es formuliert, also zum Beispiel
Festivals, Clubs und so weiter,
müssen Ungeimpfte damit leben, dass sie zum Beispiel
einen negativen PCR-Test
-bezahlen und vorweisen können?
-In welchem Zeitraum, wäre die Frage?
In einem absehbaren
Zeitraum, nicht ein Leben lang. Ist
das ein Kompromissvorschlag, wo ihr sagt,
ja, kann ich einen kleinen Schritt
-nach vorne gehen?
-Also nur zur Klärung, diesen Fall haben
wir jetzt schon. Wir haben uns ja
auch als Clubs schon darauf eingerichtet,
diese 2G-Regelung
durchzuführen und das machen auch alle Clubs.
Ich habe gesagt 3G, aber
das dritte G ist ein PCR-Test.
Achso, ja dann, das ist
ja unser Vorschlag.
Das ist euer Vorschlag, den ihr macht,
der ist aber nicht Realität momentan.
-Ne, der ist nicht Realität.
-Der ist meiner Ansicht nach auch nicht
realisierbar. Der PCR-Test braucht
zumindest auf dem Land, wo ich auch wohne,
zu lange bis er da ist,
um dann noch gültig zu sein.
Gut, in Berlin wäre
das vielleicht möglich.
-Da sind drei Stunden Tests möglich, ja.
-Das ist theoretisch möglich.
Auf dem Land fahr ich an den nächsten
Flughafen, um dann drei Stunden zu warten.
-Friedemann, warum bewegst du dich nicht?
-Die ersten zwei Sätze, die du gesagt hast,
waren hervorragend. Ganz wichtig,
dass wir zur Unterscheidung kommen. Das ist
ein Mittel und es ist ein imperfektes
Mittel, über alles, was wir hier
diskutieren. Und niemand behauptet,
das wäre ein guter oder schöner Umgang
mit der Problematik. Ich bin nicht
ganz- ich war nicht ganz zufrieden mit deiner
-Abgrenzung.
-3G, 2G?
Wo wird das genau einsetzen? Du
hast von risikobehafteten Veranstaltungen,
glaube ich, gesprochen. Das ist wieder
ein sehr weiter Begriff. Da könnten wir jetzt
wahrscheinlich wieder zwei Stunden
darüber diskutieren, wo ist jetzt das Risiko-
Ich bezweifel das gar nicht, oder ich bestreite
es gar nicht, dass nicht Clubs
-auch risikoreicher sind als ein Einkauf.
-Genau, da sind wir uns einig. Aber an
vielen anderen Stellen sind wir uns
wahrscheinlich nicht einig, mit Museen.
Museen haben wieder eine andere
Lobby als Clubs. Das geht mir dann wieder
auf die Nerven. Warum werden
die dann anders behandelt?
Also, ihr habt es gesehen. Schwierig,
so ein Kompromissvorschlag zu unterbreiten.
Jetzt seid ihr dran: Könnt ihr euch
mal unterhalten, wie könntet ihr vielleicht
die anderen auf eure Seite ziehen?
Merkt euch euren Platz ungefähr wo ihr wart
und dann bitteschön. Ja, man sieht
es schon, es ist bei dieser Fragestellung
nicht gerade einfach, eine Kompromisslinie
erst mal zu definieren. Aber vielleicht
habt ihr einen Vorschlag: Wie würdet
ihr diese beiden Parteien näher aneinander
bringen? Schreibts mal in die Kommentare,
wer weiß, vielleicht ist ja
etwas fruchtbares dabei.
Freue mich drauf. Wer will anfangen?
-Die Juristin.
-Die Juristin will anfangen.
Wir sind der Ansicht, dass wir eine allmähliche
Aufhebung aller Maßnahmen
beginnen sollten. Und zwar
jetzt, allerdings nicht sofort, also nicht
im Sinne von einem Freedom Day. Wir sehen
es, also zumindest ich sehe das juristisch
als gegeben, dass man das jetzt
sofort, eigentlich schon gestern hätte machen
müssen. Aber wir haben uns darauf
geeinigt, dass wir das nicht jetzt sofort
machen würden, sondern allmählich, wie in Dänemark
zum Beispiel. Da haben die Anfang
Juni mit der Maskenpflicht- da war
eine Impfquote bei knapp 25 Prozent- haben
sie die Maskenpflicht aufgehoben
und sukzessiv bis eben zum Freedom Day,
der jetzt Anfang September war, alle
Maßnahmen aufgehoben. Und wir appellieren,
oder unsere Vorstellung wäre, dass man
eine Risikogruppen bezogene Aufklärung
für die Impfung macht, dass man weiß,
was die Hauptrisikofaktoren für einen schweren
Verlauf sind, gezielt diese Gruppen
anspricht, um die zu gewinnen,
weil wir eben nichts davon
hielten, einfach alle gleich zu behandeln,
als hätten alle das gleiche
Risiko, denn das ist eben nicht so.
-Alle Ungeimpften?
-Richtig, genau.
Ich habe versucht, das zu verstehen.
Wir adressieren explizit die Ungeimpften
und dann aber die Risikogruppen
unter den Ungeimpften.
Die ungeimpften Risikogruppen und gleichzeitig
eine abgestufte Aufhebung.
Die Maßnahmen sind aber nicht
gekoppelt an eine Impfquote insgesamt.
-Nein.
-Also der Abbau der Maßnahmen. Okay. Habt
-ihr das verstanden?
-Ja, deswegen bin ich zurück.
Deswegen bist du zurückgegangen.
Kannst du noch mal vielleicht in aller Kürze
-erklären, warum?
-Die Aufklärung und das Belassen des
persönlichen Risikos nur für die Risikogruppen
bedeutet aber auch,
dass ich die Risikogruppen, bei denen
die Impfung, leider Gottes, nicht so gut wirkt
wie bei den normalen Menschen, die kein
Risiko haben, ich die wieder alleine
lasse. Das heißt, wenn ich keine
entsprechende Impfquote habe, dann lasse
ich die Leute mit einer Immundeffizienz,
dann lasse ich die Leute
mit einer Kortison Therapie, dann lasse
ich die Leute, die Krebs haben, dann lasse
ich die Leute, die eine Organtransplantation
haben und bei denen
die Impfung einfach unzureichend
wirkt, im Regen stehen. Das heißt, diese Leute
können weiterhin nicht am gesellschaftlichen
Leben teilnehmen.
Für die ist es weiterhin
gefährlich, obwohl sie geimpft sind.
Erik, du hast dich,
glaube ich, nicht bewegt?
-Nicht bewegt.
-Also es geht darum, sehr neutral,
-Maßnahmen nach und nach abzubauen.
-Ja, graduell auf jeden Fall.
-Graduell abzubauen.
-Das finde ich gut, dass ihr das gesagt
habt, dass das nicht sein kann oder nicht
sein wird. Das funktioniert nicht,
sondern wir müssen das Stückchen
für Stückchen machen. Auf jeden Fall.
-Okay, jetzt seid ihr dran.
-Wir waren ehrlich gesagt erst ein bisschen
-ratlos.
-Das hat man gesehen.
Gar nicht böse gemeint ratlos, weil wir uns,
glaub ich, ehrlich bemühen wollten,
einen Kompromissvorschlag zu machen
und hoffen, dass wir in einem Punkt uns
zumindest im Ziel einig sind, dass wir,
glaube ich, mehr oder weniger alle dafür
sind, mehr Impfungen in der Gesellschaft
tut allen gut beziehungsweise hilft
bei dem großen Ziel, aus der Pandemie
rauszukommen und möglichst viel Freiheit
wieder zu erlangen. In welchen Schritten?
Andere Diskussion. Und deswegen glaube
ich, ist unser Vorschlag, dass wir gerne
die Energie der Diskussion darauf lenken
würden, wie wir mehr Menschen zur Impfung
kriegen, von denen, die erreichbar wären
und die, die nicht
erreichbar sind, die eben nicht.
-Hat nicht gut funktioniert.
-Ich weiß, ja.
-Lutz ist so, ja.
-Ja, ich bin natürlich dafür, dass man
Impfangebote weiter aufrechterhält.
Und ich frage nur, wie lange. Wir reden hier
über die Verhältnismäßigkeit und wir reden
über den Zeitraum. Und wir können uns
darauf einlassen, dass wir sagen,
wir machen das über den Winter noch mal
mit Einschränkung. Aber wenn das nicht
absehbar ist, dass dann auch bei sinkenden
Zahlen auch wieder sinkende
Maßnahmen stattfinden, dann kommen wir nicht
-zusammen.
-Mir ging es weniger um Einschränkungen,
sondern mehr um Kommunikation
und Angebote, auf jeden Fall.
Also volle Energie in diejenigen,
die potenziell erreichbar sind mit einem
-Impfangebot.
-Also ich glaube, das große Stichwort war
Solidarität. Die einen verstehen
unter Solidarität, dass man sich impfen lässt
und dass man möglichst noch die Leute,
die ungeimpft sind, einschränkt.
Und meine Solidarität fängt jetzt an,
die Leute wieder zu integrieren, die wir außen
-vor gelassen haben.
-Mein Ziel wäre das, so schnell wie möglich
dieses Ziel zu erreichen.
Und das funktioniert halt leider
mit einer unpopulären Maßnahme,
denke ich eher als dieses Problem, wovon
ich der Meinung bin, wenn wir es über
3G lösen würden, künstlich in die Länge
-ziehen.
-Ich wünsche mir für die Zukunft, dass es
ein Expertengremium gibt, was nicht
aus rein virologischer Sicht die Pandemie
betrachtet, sondern alle Aspekte
dieser Pandemie mit hinein nimmt. Ein Gremium
aus Psychologen, Virologen,
Sozialpädagogen, ein runder Tisch,
an dem diese Menschen gemeinsam
diskutieren und die Politik beraten
und die Politik dann auch bitte
nicht beratungsresistent ist.
Es ist alles richtig. Meiner Meinung
nach hat es genau diese interdisziplinäre,
breite gesellschaftliche
Auseinandersetzung immer wieder gegeben.
Ich halte die Beobachtung oder das Argument,
wir würden ja nicht alle Aspekte
betrachten oder die hätten nicht
eine Stimme am Tisch sozusagen, halte
ich für eine falsche Behauptung. Wir handeln
sehr komplex aus, immer wieder.
Die Ergebnisse gefallen nicht jedem.
Das ist auch völlig in Ordnung. Insofern wäre
mein Wunsch eher, dass viele Menschen
sich noch einmal ganz ehrlich hinterfragen
und reflektieren, wo sie vielleicht
doch sich von einem Egoismus leiten lassen
und das auf den Prüfstand stellen und vielleicht
über ihren Schatten springen.
Es ist lustig. Ich habe das Gefühl,
dass wir immer so die Dinge sagen und jeder
denkt, ich meine dich mit deinem
Egoismus. Und ich denke ja, ich meine dich.
Ich glaube, ich kenne sehr viele
Leute, die egoistischer sind als du.
Okay, ich auch. Ich kenne dich gar
nicht, insofern. Okay, wir müssen ja auch keinen
-Kompromiss finden.
-Ja gut, ich denke, bei dem Thema war es
abzusehen, dass wir keine
einvernehmliche Lösung finden werden. Auf der anderen
Seite ist auch klar geworden, dass es sich
lohnt, möglichst sachlich weiter
um Kompromisse zu ringen. Gerade bei diesen Themen,
die so dermaßen emotional
aufgeladen sind. Wir brauchen
euren Support. Hier könnt ihr unseren Kanal
abonnieren. Hier oben findet ihr eine weitere
Folge 13 Fragen und hier
ein weiteres Video zum Thema. Tschüss.